we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is
someone accusing me of being a
conspiracy theorist and also of not
being that bright yeah so i just want to
note that you you're a pretender smug
pretentious person who tries to act like
you are an object and objective arbiter
of the truth that you are some why stage
of the left when the truth about it is
you actually just engage in conspiracy
theories about speculations about from
mental state and all sorts of
nonsensical things
yeah you're not that bright and god
bless you all right well I appreciate
being blessed by God but you know most
of the allegations there are of course
not true as far as the you know
speculating about Trump's mental health
I read the opinions of mental health
professionals and go by what they say of
course and as far as not being that
bright well to each their own everybody
does the best they can I think that's
all we can say we have a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
this bizarre order from Donald Trump
which will have Judaism interpreted as a
nationality I think that this makes no
sense but I don't even think that Trump
understands what it is that he wants to
do we'll talk about that we will talk
about a church nativity scene that has
gone viral we will talk about the word
of the year from merriam-webster all of
that and more on today's bonus show I
hope you'll join us become a member at
join pakman.com to get instant access to
the bonus show or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman